one of the biggest problems dogging the
incoming trump administration would be
Donald Trump's vast business holdings
conflicting with his performance as
president in the week after the election
the Washington Post reported that Trump
DC hotel officials had done outreach to
local foreign embassies Trump met with
Indian businessmen who work with his
brand Ivanka Trump took part in a state
meeting with the Japanese Prime Minister
an Argentinian reporter said the Trump
and his daughter had requested a
business favor on a phone call with the
Argentinian president by the way the
favor was later Branson Trump himself
told the New York Times that he'd be
capable of running his president along
his business alongside his presidency
all of that was kind of disquieting but
Trump actually understands the problem
now he tweeted this morning quote I will
be holding a major news conference in
New York City with my children on
December 15th to discuss the fact that I
will be leaving my great business in
total in order to fully focus on running
the country in order to all caps make
America great again while i am not
mandated to do this under the law but
feel that is visually important as
president to in no way have a conflict
of interest with my various businesses
hence legal documents are being crafted
which take me completely out of business
operations the presidency is a far more
important task so here's the deal this
isn't enough we still need to know
exactly how these legal documents will
shape up is Trump giving up his
ownership stake there's no indicator he
is well his children continue to run the
business and yet continue to also advise
him in his role as president that would
actually maintain the conflict will
trump liquidate his businesses really
really unlikely in a joint statement
Richard painter who's George w's ethics
lawyer and Norma Nelson who's Obama's
ethics lawyer they said Trump's
continued business interest would quote
sometimes conflict with the public
interest and constantly raise questions
but but at least Trump recognizes the
problem that's at least half the battle
we can actually hope that he'll be
cautious enough to silo his businesses
and political interests preventing the
taint of his scandal from destroying his
White House before it launches good for
Trump now let's pray that he carries out
his pledge I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
alrighty so here we are lots to get to
today were going to be having on adam
carolla in just a few moments to discuss
his new movie has a new documentary i'll
call the 24-hour war i've watched most
of it it is really really good really
fascinating and about the American auto
industry and about car racing in general
talk to Adam in just a second but first
we have to say hello to our friends over
at Legacy box so this is an advertiser I
feel very strongly about its legacy box
calm / been the way legacy box works is
they allow you to keep all of your
memories by basically sent in all your
old films we're talking reels we're
talking VHS videos and they convert all
of this stuff to a digital file they put
it on a CD or they put it on a or they
put it on a thumb drive for you so you
can keep this stuff forever its legacy
box calm / spending at a forty percent
discount on your order so old photos
cassettes home videos my parents are
doing this right now they're gathering
up all of my dad's old film reels his
dad's old film reel so these are 50 60
years old and legacy box they stamp them
all with a with a they put a sticker on
there with a barcode so you can actually
see we're in the process all of your
film is they have experts who go through
it make sure that it still works make
sure that it's all in order and I'm very
big on preserving memories of the past
because I think you lose the past you
lose your family history that's a real
tragedy there's a reason why when
everybody says there's a fire you grab
your photo album there's a reason why
they do that and right now this allows
you instead of have 20 boxes full of
stuff you'll never look at in your
garage now you have it all on a
convenient thumb drive or DVD so you can
actually enjoy it and take part in it
legacy box calm / Ben that's a forty
percent discount on your order it can be
really really expensive you do this just
on your own legacy box makes it really
easy and really convenient legacy
box.com / bend and to get that forty
percent discount on your order okay so
joining us on the line is oh actually
sorry he'll be joining us shortly so
we'll get to that in just a second first
we'll jump right into the news so the
big news of the day yesterday was that
mittens Mitt Romney met with Donald
Trump and I do love how this went down
so basically they met and here's a
picture of that well first of all I just
need to set the stage here's what Mitt
Romney said about Donald Trump during
the campaign if you recall
if we make improvident choices the
bright horizon I've described will not
materialize and let me put it very
plainly if we Republicans choose Donald
Trump as our nominee the prospect for a
safe and prosperous future are greatly
diminished if Donald Trump's plans were
ever implemented the country would sink
into prolonged recession a few examples
his proposed 35-percent tariff like
penalties would instigate a trade war
and that would raise prices for
consumers kill our export jobs and lead
auto phony to right he says that Trump
is a phony is a con man he's a liar
basically this is a pretty brutal speech
if your call is in march during the
primaries and and so you know bottom
line is that romney was not very
friendly to trump and now they get
together for dinner and here's the
picture of them at dinner is stunningly
good oh it's just wonderful i love it so
much okay i will say that this
presidency thus far has been wildly
entertaining the picture of Trump with
Obama was great enough this picture just
the way that it's lit in the expressions
on their face so spectacular for folks
who aren't gonna be listening to this
laker like it romney's face romney's
like oh my god what happened to me right
this is a typical this is like the photo
freeze frame how did I get here well let
me explain from the beginning and then
he whined at six months it's incredible
so there's his face go back to the first
picture for a second the first picture
of Trump sitting there and he's lit from
the bottom like you're in a campfire and
they're doing like oh you're gonna tell
a horror story and he's lit from below
and his face is right it's like it looks
like Mitt Romney just signed away his
soul in a really bad business deal to
Donald Trump and from sitting there
grinning like Satan like the Cheshire
Cat is just spectacular in every way I
love it so much just that the fact that
Romney keeps going there and going there
just to like get slapped around and
people are getting very funny about this
like for example look at look at this is
the Trump Romney dinner and the first
thing that popped into my head is of
course from the little mermaid yeah
that's that's
that was the first thing that popped
into my head when I saw that picture
because that's exactly what it looks
like the other one that popped into my
head of course was it was from and
silence of the lambs so just horrifying
just round me being fed his own brain by
Donald Trump the best one though is this
it was this tweet that somebody had they
put it in black and white this picture
and in black and white is even better
since I made the Trump Romney photo
black and white and it looks like a
Twilight Zone episode where a guy just
made a foolish a deal with the devil and
of course is exactly rice so spectacular
oh my god so good the woman's making the
rounds a lot is this what hahaha it's
great somebody Photoshop Trump and
Romney into the dinner scene from from
Empire Strikes Back where Han Solo walks
into the room and realizes the land o is
sold about and Darth Vader is sitting at
the other end of the long table and it
is it is pretty amazing it is pretty
amazing it is also worth noting by the
way that remember when Donald Trump
brand is a blue-collar working class
hero remember that and now he's worth
like he's dead what ten billion dollars
Mitt Romney's 100 millionaire and here's
what their menu was the other night this
is the menu it's a three-star michelin
rated restaurant and called them what's
this stupid is called jean-georges
jean-georges a is what is called
jean-georges as i like to call and here
was the actual menu quote the appetizer
was young garlic soup with time and
sauteed frog legs next they had diver
scallops with caramelized cauliflower
and a caper raisin emulsion for their
main course both Priebus and the
president-elect had prime sirloin with
citrus glaze and carrots romney had lamb
chops with the mushroom polonaise sauce
all three a chocolate cake for dessert
sounds like many people to make and no
corrupt bargains happening among the
people who are eating frog legs although
I have to say poor Pepe poor Pepe I mean
they they they ran this entire campaign
and Pepe was with Trump the entire way
and then Trump just ate him and
somewhere the alt right cries and tears
of sorrow rolled down Pepe's cheeks it
is all very very tragic then Mitt Romney
came out afterward and he made this
statement after the dinner and he just
looks I mean Trump and his people had
asked for basically an apology from Mitt
Romney and Romney
clearly wants the gig and so now he's
apologizing pretty amazing engages
enjoying the very much I was also very
impressed by the remarks he made on his
victory knife by the way it's not easy
when I know that myself he did something
I try to do and was unsuccessfully he'd
want the generalist and and he continues
with a message of inclusion bringing
people together and his vision is
something which obviously connected with
the American people in a very powerful
way wings joke right it's a joke I mean
Romney's is looking for an excuse to
jump back on the Trump train here and
he's finding it in you know his his
speech and his cabinet Romney still
thinks went from exactly what Romney
always thought of Trump there are two
ways to read Romney's behavior here one
is Romney really really really really
wants back into power that's the cynical
way to read this the other way to read
this is that Romney believes and things
that Trump could use some stayed steady
sober judgment around him and so he's
willing to undergo the humiliation of
dealing with Trump and maybe being
thrown under the bus by Trump in order
to do it and again Trump hasn't selected
him yet for Secretary of State so this
could all go wildly wrong right there
only two possible ways this plays out as
far as as far as Romney is concerned in
terms of public image these are both
from Game of Thrones the way number one
this turns out for Romney just in terms
of how this plays out politically is is
this is this right here what is to be
done with this traitor your grace so
long as I am your king treason shall
never go unpunished
like that that's that's that's possible
that he goes out he makes his obese
institute rump and then Trump a heads
him and picks rudy giuliani which would
be hilarious i will say it would be
really really funny the other way that
this could go is is that Trump actually
gives him what he wants but that
involves him being a little bit
humiliated go on me nice clothes
hey I could go reek ready could be read
in reality the truth is a lot of the
stuff is overplayed Trump likes to play
reality TV it is reality TV it's very
entertaining I will admit that and I
have all of my Bachelorette outtakes for
when he actually makes this call because
the Bachelorette outtakes will fit
Giuliani or Romney one of the two will
be sobbing in a car about how they were
so deeply in love and then they were
left at the altar but in reality is that
is Trump playing this right Trump is
playing this about as well as he could
have played this really i mean he's
making Romney look foolish he's making
Romney look like he has to bend the knee
to him and then if he actually picks
Romney it's a brilliant move politically
because it looks like he's getting over
his own pettiness about Romney in order
to stock his cabinet with people who are
good and if he doesn't pick Romney well
then he's done what a lot of people
expected him to do on his own side you
know in his own base and he stomped
Romney in the face and and he's going to
get a lot of credit for that from his
own base so he's in a no-lose situation
I'm Romney played along i assume out of
patriotism and a sense of duty but it
could have also been out of ego both are
possible but it is fascinating to watch
this sort of stuff typically is not done
in front of the cameras and yet Trump is
doing it all in front of the cameras
which is going to make for a very very
entertaining very entertaining for years
you mean while Trump is being given a
lot of credit for this for carrier
keeping a bunch of jobs a carrier is an
air conditioner manufacturer and they
just they just announced they're going
to keep a thousand jobs in Indiana and I
want to talk about this in a pretty
serious way because I think that a lot
of people are ignoring the real story
here and that's a problem so a lot of
people are immediately celebrating the
fact that Trump kept jobs in America
that's great okay that's that's that's
wonderful except for that's not the
actual story lots of people can use the
government to keep jobs in a particular
place Barack Obama used the power of
government the threat of the pitchforks
and torches to leverage the banks to do
things that he wanted Barack Obama was
able to make the auto companies come on
bended knee to him in order so that he
could get them to do what he wanted by
threatening them the bottom line here is
not the thousand job saved the bottom
line is what we still don't know which
is what did Trump do to get carrier to
keep its jobs there so a lot of people
are saying we shouldn't even ask the
question we should just sort of accept
what it is we should just sort of take
it how it is no big problem no big issue
you know
at least he kept the jobs here that in
and of itself is wonderful and that
would be okay except for the fact that
how you use the government is really the
issue for me not necessarily the outcome
you can always keep a company here
listen if I were in charge of the
federal government pick a company in
America I could keep it here just by
paying them a lot of money I could bribe
a company to stay here or alternatively
I could threaten that company in order
to make them stay here right the power
of the presidency is vast the power of
the federal government is vast the
question is what did Trump do in order
to ensure the carrier would stay so
here's what we know we don't know
anything really because Trump has not
announced what the deal was Mike Pence's
the governor of Indiana he's the one
really offering the incentives because
he's still governor of Indiana carrier
is located in Indiana so we still have
to figure out exactly what Pence offered
and this does make a difference here's
what we know or at least the little that
we do know according to the New York
Times united technologies which is the
owner of carrier is among the country's
biggest military contractors producing
engines for the Pentagon's most advanced
fighter jets receiving more than 5
billion dollars annually from the
federal government that equals ten
percent of the company's revenue so
there's the idea that perhaps Trump said
we'll have the Defense Department cut
our contracts to you if you move those
jobs okay that's bad that's bad that's
the cut that's the government leveraging
businesses into making bad business
decisions through threat right not
getting the best deal for the American
people because presumably the reason
that they're contracting with United
Technologies is because united
technologies provides the best service
at the best price here's what we know
courtesy of CNBC quote while terms of
the deal are not yet clear the sources
indicated there were new incentives on
offer from the state of Indiana where
Pence's governor that helped clear path
for the agreement well while United
technology was seeking the savings that
would come from moving some production
to Mexico people familiar with the
situation indicated the savings were not
worth incurring the wrath of the
incoming administration including the
potential threat to the significant
business united technologies currently
conducts with the US government largely
in the form of orders for jet engines
and other defense related equipment so
it's the federal government leveraging
people now I don't like the federal
government leveraging people whether the
person at the head of the federal
government is a Republican or a Democrat
that is not the job of the federal
government the job of the federal
government is to preserve your rights
and if it has contracts that it needs to
do then it should contract the best
available operator not the operator
that makes bad financial decisions in
order to please the federal government
right that's a backdoor form of bribery
from united technologies and by the way
this also sets up a pretty bad precedent
a company says we're gonna move 2,000
jobs to Mexico and then they wait for
Trump to come in with a noodle of cash
and just dump it on them okay this is
not that this is not particularly a rip
on trumpets it's a rip on the policies
that are bad I don't have a look Trump
made a promise and Trump is trying to
keep that promise but the way you keep
the promise matters to me the principal
doesn't change just because the name of
the guy in power changes and I
understand everybody's going to
celebrate the thousand jobs but these
kinds of headlines routinely routinely
come out from administration's ranging
from Barack Obama's to Hugo Chavez is
the question isn't whether carrier keeps
the thousand jobs in Indiana the
question is why they kept a thousand
jobs in Indiana if carrier kept the
thousand jobs in Indiana if they kept
the thousand jobs in Indiana because
Donald Trump was pursuing positive
economic policies that benefit everyone
and they say in expectation of lower
taxes and an expectation of loosened
regulations we've decided that we're
going to keep the jobs here wonderful
all credit to trump if they say we're
keeping the thousand jobs here because
Donald Trump bribed us or because Donald
from threatened us that's not something
that I'm cool with and as conservative
you shouldn't be cool with that either
because that's just using government to
pick winners and losers and as I am fond
of saying I'm old enough to remember
when we thought that was bad when Obama
did with green jobs and stimulus
packages and auto bailouts and bank
threats again Barack Obama actually used
the threat of pitchforks and torches he
actually said he brought bankers to the
White House in the early part of his
administration he said my administration
is the only thing between you and the
pitchforks and then he leveraged them
into doing what he wanted he did the
same thing to the health insurance
companies he said to them listen I'm
going to offer a public option if you
don't cave to me and give me what I want
that was bad it wouldn't be any better
if Trump did it hey who go Chavez used
to do this Hugo Chavez actually had a
show the Venezuelan socialist dictator
he actually had to show in Venezuela
when it was called hello president that
was the name of the show it was a full
day show he literally go on camera at
like eight in the morning on Sundays all
the way to like six in the evenings and
the producer of the show would explain
this way said the president decides
everything it's his show it was called
hello president because people would
call in but it became like lottery
everyone looking to get a job
a house or something Chavez would
literally give jobs to people on the air
people would call in so I don't have a
job Chavez would say I'll give you a job
look at my magnificence the only way he
could give a job of course was to take a
job away from somebody else or to take
money away from somebody else now this
is this is the definition of the swamp
okay when people talk about the swamp
needs to be drained and crony capitalism
this is the definition of it and it
doesn't become good just because our
guys are doing it so before we get too
excited about the carrier decides to
keep a thousand jobs in the United
States headline let's find out how it
was done if the headline said
cylindrical you now Obama promises we'd
all be saying wait a second that's
bribery you can't do that again
consistency in principle I know people
get upset with consistency in principle
I know people get very upset with the
idea that we're going to hold everybody
to the same standard or they were going
to mandate the Donald Trump actually act
in accordance with conservatism but the
fact is that if we don't hold him
accountable for his sins then who are we
going to hold them accountable to like
who's going to be accountable the way
the whole president's accountable is
making them accountable for their
behavior so I hope that Trump reveals
his plan and his plan is get rid of
regulations get rid of taxation lower
the corporate tax rate that's why
carrier kept the jobs if that happens I
will celebrate louder and longer than
anyone because that will be excellent
Trump not good Trump excellent Trump but
if this was just another crony
capitalist payoff to carrier so that he
could have his headline in his moment in
the Sun where he said that he kept
carrier there with its thousand jobs as
a bunch of crap and it's crap whether a
Democrat doesn't and it's crap whether
there's a Republican that does it okay
this these things do not change just
because the name at the top of the
ticket changes the name of the White
House changes the minute you sacrifice
principle for political convenience the
principal no longer matters it no longer
matters so before you celebrate
headlines let's look for the actual
content of the story right for example
i'm willing to give Trump the benefit of
the doubt right now on is he going to
separate from his business he's gonna
have to fill that out with content if
the content is my kids will run the
business and they'll also advise me in
the White House the conflict still
exists if he separates off and his kids
run the business and they have nothing
to do at the White House good for him
I'll be cheering because I want his
presidency to be a success I want him to
govern like Ronald Reagan I would love
to see it I would love to be wrong about
him I would but we have to call out bad
things when we see them and we can't
just
hey that they're good if they're not
right we actually have to see evidence
of good we just have to see evidence and
good that's all and this whole idea you
know Steve benen is said this we're
gonna create a fifty-year dominance
based on big government spending and
Obama stimulus packages it was bad when
Obama did it it's bad when Trump doesn't
beat a dead horse here okay now as far
as the the sort of drain the swamp
language as far as the drain the swamp
language remember everybody's chanting
drain the swamp drain the swamp let's go
through some of the pics that Trump has
made we're still waiting on Secretary of
State the people who are currently up
for it I guess Bolton has fallen out of
contention or the latest reports which
is too bad he was my number one choice I
think Bolton knows the State Department
knows that place has to be absolutely
gutted and knows how foreign policy
works but he's fallen out for some
reason probably because he and Trump
don't agree on foreign policy that's
actually one more bizarre aspects of the
Romney thing is that no one has actually
said that Romney shouldn't be Secretary
of State because he and Trump disagree
on foreign policy and they do right
Romney was super anti Russian Trump was
very very Pro Russian during the
campaign they really disagree on this
stuff the only real criticism has been
that Romney rip Trump during the
primaries but in any case the I guess it
sounded like corker and Romney and
Giuliani those are the one end Petraeus
are the ones that they're discussing all
big names of the people who are left
Romney and Petraeus would probably be at
the top metal is probably Romney at the
top of the list then Petraeus then
Giuliani and then core core core core
would be the worst of all of them if
he's picked I'll explain why but some of
the other pics that Trump has made these
are pretty typical establishment
Republican pics he actually just picked
a bunch of Democrats he actually just
picked a bunch of Democrats to staff out
his administration it isn't quite
draining the swamp and we'll explain all
of those things if you go to daily wire
calm right now and subscribe there's
plenty more to come here on the show got
to talk about the persecution of
Christians that is being attempted by
the left media which is really insane
they're attacking now the gains family
these home builders on TV we'll talk
about that I have a lot to say about
that and we have some pretty awesome
things I hate coming up plus some bible
talk so lots coming up here on the bench
shapiro show go to daily wire calm to
subscribe eight bucks a month gets you a
subscription annual subscription gets
you a free copy of my novel signed plus
there are lots of goodies coming up
tomorrow is the mailbag you get to be
part of the mailbag if you're a
subscribe
her and you get to be part of the
largest podcast the canal are just
conservative podcast in the United
States
you